[SIREN]
NICK PATON WALSH: When the
blasts pause in rare quiet
in Toretsk, there are
few blessings to count
and most are bitter.
One is here, a familiar
scene of private worlds
torn open by a Russian
rocket two days earlier.
But a place that might persuade
you to believe in miracles.
19 people were trapped up here
when rubble blocked the stairs.
But somehow, not one of
them was even injured.
A fire brigade ladder
getting them all out.
Not even survivors
like Natalia know how.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: A noise.
I blinked twice
and couldn't see.
The balcony door flew
open and trash blew in.
I'm terrified of flames.
And I realized we're
on the seventh floor.
And it's collapsing.
Then, someone screamed don't
come out as there's no way.
It's a miracle.
I can't call it anything else.
NICK PATON WALSH: As
Putin's fake referenda,
just a few miles away,
threatened yet worse here.
Just now, the
shelling has finally
become too much for some.
[BARKING]
Rescuers are evacuating Nina,
73, after six months living
alone without water or help.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NICK PATON WALSH: We're
told she's the last person
to leave her block.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NICK PATON WALSH: Two days
ago, a rocket hit her building.
Yet also magically, she
was unscathed and just
sat here under the gaping hole.
The lonely agony of the
struggle before this moment
lying around.
The pictures of life left,
of her A-student daughter
who died of meningitis, aged 40,
of the choices of what to leave
and what to take, of
how hard just eating,
washing, and drinking has been.
Winter will rip through here.
And this may be the last time
the lights go out on this home.
She's taken to the courtyard
where dozens of similar agonies
are gathered.
Waiting for the evacuation bus.
Even after six months hell,
faces that know still worse
is coming and that are baffled
by the heaviest question.
Why?
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NICK PATON WALSH:
Elena is leaving.
She does not know where to
with her three children.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- There are some [INAUDIBLE].
NICK PATON WALSH: Then,
the guns pick up again.
Even in leaving, there's
a sense of urgency
because artillery firing
from near where we are.
Well, that's been responded
to by the Russians.
And a shell landed over here.
So they're trying to
get people on a bus
as fast as they can to
get them out of here.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NICK PATON WALSH: Dozens
of lives with everything
left behind them and
nothing certain ahead.
Nick Paton Walsh, CNN, Toretsk.